foreign
thousands of people in New Delhi joined
supporters of the Indian National
Congress party most are here for this
man Rahul Gandhi he's been leading a
march across India for three months
walking thousands of kilometers often
joined by celebrities he says his aim is
to unite a country polarized by the
governing BJP
this March is for Common People Like Us
because the government's message is
reaching us but our message and our
issues are not reaching the government
that's why I'm joining Rahul Gandhi's
March
Gandhi is the most powerful name in
Indian politics three members of the
family have served as prime minister and
India's main National opposition party
Congress governed India for more than 50
years but now it's down to one of its
lowest tallies in Parliament and is
struggling to survive meanwhile the
governing BJP enjoys unprecedented
support and prime minister Narendra Modi
has redefined Indian politics although
there are growing concerns about its
handling of the economy shrinking space
for descent and rights of minority
groups for the Congress to pose a viable
challenge it will have to address
allegations of corruption and nepotism
within its ranks Congress recently
elected a new president the first from
outside the Gandhi family in 24 years
the party says the March has helped it
reconnect with people I think the ayats
are like this also tells people who
really my leader Rahul Gandhi is because
so much of money so much of corporate
power and so much of mindset whether
it's from the troll armies or the BJP
was spent to destroy brand Rahul Gandhi
and a lot of people bought it but some
political analysts say a weak Congress
Could Make Way for other players ahead
of general elections in 2024. at the
moment what it seems like that that the
BJP has a much stronger base and is
governing with her at least nationally
is governing with a bigger mandate but
it but in states is facing a competition
so in few years you might see a party
that gets replaced that replaces
Congress as emerges as a opposition
Gandhi will March for another 700
kilometers over the next few weeks he
says he's not doing it to get votes but
the party hopes it'll give much needed
momentum as it fights for relevance Al
Jazeera New Delhi